si el exmandatario ha llegado a primera
hora de la mañana este edificio que
estáis viendo detrás de mí que se
encuentran las oficinas del fiscal
general de nueva york allí se ha acogido
a la quinta enmienda que le da derecho a
no declarar para autoinculparse ante las
preguntas ante el interrogatorio del
fiscal general de nueva york que
investiga un posible fraude fiscal
financiero en las empresas de la familia
trump al parecer esta investigación
civil se está centrando en que la
compañía tram podría haber engañado
acerca del valor de sus activos
engañando a prestamistas ya las
autoridades fiscales de nueva york a lo
largo de esta investigación ya han
declarado los hijos de donald trump pero
el exmandatario es una cita que hacía
meses que trataba de retrasar la última
vez que se retrasó fue precisamente
cuando falleció la primera mujer de
donald tram iván atravesó fue a mediados
de julio pero hoy ha tenido que venir
aquí a prestar declaración se esperaba
que fuese una declaración que durará
horas pero se ha solucionado al final en
un minuto porque como digo se ha acogido
a ese derecho a la quinta enmienda algo
por lo que muchos medios de comunicación
le han criticado porque él mismo en el
2016 en un meeting de campaña dijo que
no entendía por qué si alguien era
inocente se acogía a la quinta enmienda
pues bien hoy en un largo comunicado en
el que ha explicado que se había acogido
a la quinta enmienda y por qué lo había
hecho dice que ahora lo entiende que
cuando tu familia y tus empresas
familiares están siendo objetivo de una
caza de brujas no te queda más remedio
que hacer eso desde luego está siendo
una semana muy complicada a nivel liga
legal para el ex mandatario después de
que el fbi registrará su mansión en
florida y además no olvidemos que tiene
otra causa penal abierta que está siendo
investigada por el fiscal del distrito
de manhattan